from Yahoo entertainment Alec Baldwin
May soon be criminally charged in Rust
shooting new letter shows we got him we
got it boys finally got him
I can't believe how long it's been I was
worried he was going to get away with it
I heard he was like locking up his house
and everything his 29 million dollars oh
my goodness didn't he just have a baby
didn't his wife keep getting away with
it apparently he can't and it is the
shooting of God Rest her soul Helena
Hutchins yes who lost her life on set
after Alex
accidentally
inadvertently we should say allegedly
inadvertently look at this fired uh
bullet D.A Mary karmic altwise filed an
emergency request for 635 500 fund five
thousand funds she says are necessary to
prosecute up to four people in
connection with the accident the LA
Times obtained a letter in which karmic
altues lays out her office is
considering homicide charges as well as
gun violations so we don't know for sure
who those people are but come on why
would it not be Alec Baldwin homeboy is
gonna get criminally charged we'll see
what happens they're gonna give him a
slap on the rest still but a homicide
charge my favorite uh we covered the
story today
um Josh Young wrote it for us my
favorite part was when he said it says
no no Baldwin said I would never point a
gun and pull the pull that trigger at
them never in August an FBI analysis
concluded that Alec Baldwin pulled the
trigger of the gun that killed
cinematographer yeah I think it's a
obviously he pulled this trigger
obviously he did this thing whether he
intended to do it or not and then you
saw the there's the video of him from
set talking about
um or showing like how he pulls the gun
out and he said he didn't have his
finger on the trigger and he does have
this finger on the trigger he lied yeah
he did he lied he shot that lady and I
think he can't handle it I think he
can't handle that he did this thing I I
said it way back when and I'll say it
again but I think he probably did it The
Simple Solution is that he intentionally
killed this woman in the conspiracy
theory is that this weird final
destination-esque thing occurred where
he accidentally shot and killed her like
the crazy thing to me about the whole
story is that let's say the wrong person
had the gun and then real bullets were
accidentally put in it Alec Baldwin
still would have had to have pulled the
trigger while pointing it at her yeah
and so it's like you can believe this
thing happened where like the gun is
like on the table and then someone like
slams a door and it falls down lands
perfectly upright and the the the
whatever it's called the revolver the
wheel comes out and then bolts roll Then
Fall and Landing it perfectly and then
it rolls over and closes and then
someone picks up and puts it back on the
counter and then they open it and they
hand it out like all those weird things
could have happened I guess anything
crazy yeah look Baldwin just killed a
lady that he was presumably seems more
likely fighting with over what was going
on in the set I think someone hated Alec
and loaded that gun behind everybody's
back and then they just because they
were so negligent on set no one checked
it and then he went he was play toying
like he was an 11 year old kid like I
want to kill him oh and he's like
fantasizing about killing her with an
empty gun and then there's actually a
bullet so so here's the thing here's the
thing pretty good the issue with that is
that it requires you to make up a
circumstance that's yeah for sure
my scenario is that Alec Baldwin was
seen in a meeting with her he was seen
having dinner with her they were not
friends he called her very aggressive
and intense in a previous interview
there were problems on set those things
are facts do you think he meant to kill
her yes I thought what I think is that
the most likely outcome maybe it's only
five percent but you know for Ian's
point that someone secretly loaded the
gun you're making up why there's no
evidence and no circumstance to support
why someone would do that the motive
would be that they hated Alec Baldwin
because he was such a horrible producer
and the set was so grueling people were
unhappy
I don't think they knew what was gonna
happen they were going to frame him for
murder basically see the problem with
that is you're saying the crew was angry
that we know so they put a real bullet
in his gun but that would end up
injuring not Alec Baldwin so it's like
perhaps you can assume the person who
would have done that was Reckless and
also didn't care that they would kill an
innocent person I think that's a bigger
leap than Alec Baldwin was fighting with
a woman who was a crew member and the
crew were having problems so he shot her
so Ian's Ian's version though would do
really well on something like Magnum PI
yeah that's right right yeah it will be
it will there will be a movie of the
week about this right it would be a
terrific uh it would be a terrific
mystery well so if this just Fletcher
would figure it out okay I don't know I
don't know never mind if this so if this
goes the trial then are they going to
try and figure intent is that what this
is all about to figure out what the
depends how they charge him with
so I don't I don't know man a lot of
people were like he's an actor he was
handed the gun it's not his fault and
I'm like do you think that matters he's
an actor he's standing the gun and it is
his fault yeah as well as the producer's
fault for not overreaching the Armor's
fault yeah he's one of the like four or
five producers so all the producers
might be on the hook for this I wouldn't
be surprised if they charge the armorer
because she handed the gun the assistant
director who I think the ad actually
handed the gun to Alec and he wasn't
supposed to have his hands on that gun
well they were also struggling with
production and people were complaining
on set that the the film wasn't budgeted
correctly and a lot of the staff were
asking for a proper budget for the movie
so there was you know a lot of disputes
a lot of arguments what really happened
here I don't know only one person should
be criminally charged in a salad Baldwin
yeah if someone hands you a gun for any
reason and you pointed another person
pull the hammer back and then pull the
trigger or you've already got the
trigger depressed you shot that person
it's crazy to me that there's like the
Liberals are arguing the left is arguing
that because he's an actor he's in some
special privileged class and I'm like I
I don't know I don't know that makes no
sense to me I don't care if you're an
actor or not if like someone's like
we're doing a stunt and I'm gonna give
you a sledgehammer but don't actually
you know swing it at my face and then
you do it's like you hit him in the face
if they had waivers signed and it was
like Hey we're gonna be swinging
sidechambers everyone's saying if
something happens to me then the
production's not responsible because we
don't know it's very risky and they know
the risk ahead of time and someone gets
killed that's a different story perhaps
I don't know if that's a different I
don't know that you could uh like up
your liability for getting killed do you
know what I mean like it's but it is a
fair point that Helena Hutchins knew he
would be pointing the gun at her and she
chose to be there under those
circumstances so that probably does put
it more Sim simply as it into an
accidental space like the sledgehammer
thing could work but if you're like
doing a magic trick where you're
supposed to swing a sledgehammer at
someone and they escape before you hit
them and then they get hit well in that
case like you the person with a
sledgehammer were telling them to do it
and apparently they're saying on the
film Helena Hutchins is telling Alec
Baldwin to pull the trigger oh wow well
she's like telling him at this point
yeah get the shot get the shot get the
shot and Alec is getting frustrated and
frustrated or something and then he
finally goes off and hits her I gotta
like see it happening it's so crazy it's
just such a casual thing that could go
wrong which is why gun safety is so
important but that's a thing like they
shouldn't use real guns
no they shouldn't use real guns I was
working on a show Once a play and we had
a shotgun in the play and we were using
a real gun but there were no bullets on
set anywhere but it was still like super
intense
um and a big deal if you were handling
the gun you know there were like
intensive rules about if you were
handling handling the gun even though
there were no bullets anywhere you know
on set at all yeah there was supposedly
no live rounds on set for this movie too
it's whatever we didn't have like not
only no we had nothing nothing ever went
in the gun but like it we were so
careful with that thing I just want to
point this out in the Yahoo
entertainment story It Ends by saying
this more Alec Baldwin feared he would
be killed by Trump supporters over rust
shooting it's not a link
what does that mean there's no link
there do a little search of that they
just what is that they just added this
to the end of the story like oh as an
aside Trump supporters were going to
kill him he thinks why would they put
that at the bottom of the story maybe he
was in the car with that guy in North
Dakota you know he was like him and that
guy are super tight apparently man did
you see that SNL is like they think it's
going to end oh let's talk about it
really well they lost eight members why
because the show's garbage they have
their first but they have their first
non-binary member so obviously it's
going to do amazing right now okay you
know what Edie what's her name is it
left the show
80. oh really but didn't they were like
right they were like building with 80
Bryant they really oh they had oh yeah
they had a feature player yeah too so
they had eight people drop out I don't
know exactly what happened but here's
the issue you used to have like three or
four channels what was that you'd have
like three or four channels that was
good and you you turn on the nightly the
night show whatever late night show or
whatever and then on Saturday it's SNL
everybody watched it because that was
what to watch on Saturday now you've got
a million channels you've got a million
influencers you got all these different
videos and what's going on
what I don't know is that me not me it's
that weird noise
what are you doing anyway the point is
SNL doesn't matter anymore because
there's two there's on demand video you
can watch it anytime they should just
call it NL they should just do sketch
counts just live they should make a
YouTube channel where they randomly just
upload yeah that's exactly what they
should do now forget the Saturday night
thing it's grueling for the actors
anyway they all know it's like boot camp
that's not funny yeah it's stretched
it's like they're I don't know I don't
watch it anymore no I haven't watched it
in years and years I've seen some real
painful sketches I think common is a
genius I love that guy rewatched more
Monty Python than I've watched yeah
comedy should be free and it should be a
critique of our society but now our our
society can't be critiqued we can't
laugh at certain ideas we can't laugh at
certain hot button issues which defeats
the whole purpose of Comedy which of
course it was kind of a a tool in
society that made things easy that that
made people laugh that that brought
people together and and I think the way
that Society is is really being pushed
into this this really negative way that
that comedy isn't allowed and SNL being
off the air and potentially losing its
entire show uh I think highlights this
we used to be able to laugh at other
people's suffering which is kind of
horrible to think of but that was like a
big part of freedom is you're allowed to
make fun of whoever you want and this
moral police of today even like in
Canada like you might even get arrested
for doing it sometimes for making people
uncomfortable or whatever just intro
dough well no no no no no no no no no if
like you make them uncomfortable by
saying naughty words perhaps but if you
make them uncomfortable by wearing big
old fake Novelties yeah now we're
talking then you're you're accepted you
can do whatever you want as soon as you
got these things on I personally don't
like making fun of other people's pain I
don't like doing it personally I see
someone do it someone else I find it
derogatory and hateful I'm like well I
don't like that but that's comedy man
that's the history of it and you know
damn be the consequences I guess maybe
but if you're able to laugh at something
difficult in life you're able to of
course turn it around for being
something so negative so a lot of the
times we deal with something very
serious we deal with that something
that's that's impacting us laughing at
it even though it might be something
that that hurts you a lot of the times
helps a lot of people deal with a lot of
the trauma in our society like covid
people lost people with coveted so if
people were making jokes about that like
oh yeah grandma in the hospital and
doing a joke like 100 years ago and then
you do the whole too soon like that's a
meme is it too soon to joke about
because it just happened but like you
couldn't I couldn't even speak out about
the science of covid while it was
happening about getting banned off of
Facebook it was crazy to figure it out
Trump should start selling search shirts
and hats that say the great reset and it
should be like with my election in 2024
I'm going to reset the establishment
we're going to change everything and go
back back to when it was great by
resetting it that way all of the elites
are forced to say the great race is a
bad thing thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there